okay so wait NE next we're going to go
to what's interesting little number so
oh yeah yeah yeah that's from me too
that's actually from Mr tight sleeves
over here I heard you had a a new book
oh you know what I'm going to pass this
uh that's actually that's actually a
book Mark nice nice Yeah scratch and
sniff too scratch and sniff never lose
your
place
yep okay wa this smells terrible thank
you yeah really he's like you're
welcome wait who are these whose are
these are the what are these I like
these you look you look like a Monster
yeah you look like a Sesame Street
monster the first time I've been told
yeah no no no it's it's it's a good I
want you want to try these on try that
on come on you think you're good-looking
now wait a
minute exactly
exactly I'll be
f
ready for Halloween I like it wait so so
I should have had those when a did
Terminator I know no trust me your
glasses were cool in that
[Music]
[Applause]
um thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home